ton nom bigard prénom jean marie c'est
tout à peu près jean marie marcelle
stade et surnom je te demande
ouais j'en avais un que j'étais à
l'école m'appeler bigou et tapez ps
appelle comment appelle t elle m'appelle
pas si fait la faillite intrigue
m'appelle pas trop date de naissance 17
mai 54 télé cheveux gras mouillé gras ou
sait qu'ils sont nombreux et je
t'emmerde pas mal les dieux avoir les
yeux des yeux marrons sept cochons
tatoués lentilles way hypermétropes je
suis hyper mettre un fait ça c'est pas
beau me vanter mais je me débrouille
bien des bornes non je m'appelle jean
marie mais il ya des limites quand même
cicatrices oui j'en ai je n'ai eu une
petite c'est une ride d'expression on
appelle ça plaît aux femmes est pareil
c'est dû à quoi ça c'est dû à quoi tu te
poses des questions mâchonnement luta
https veste et attaquant du de fringues
doigts vas-y continue mais tu commence
un peu à me courir sur le haricot
hostilités les verrues non j'ai arrêté
j'étais à deux paquets par jour j'ai
arrêté tu portes des slips
oui des slips de terrassement des fois
ça dépend dans quelle part tous tu vas
ça dépend tu fais me convient de paquets
par jour
ça dépend chum si je fais la
ribouldingue fumeux deux et demi avec
une bouteille de whisky puis sinon j
allume des fois ma première clope avant
de jouer le soir tout va et je fume
trois quatre clubs dans la journée sauf
que je me quand je me mets quoi c'est
une question de volonté jédir on peut
fumer davantage faut s'accrocher du tout
est ce que tu as des rapports sexuels
ailleurs que dans un lit mais je te
demande bien sûr toi aussi je suppose ou
par exemple partout machine à vue en
position essorage
as tu eu recours à l'amour tarifé un
même tarif et oui ça m'est déjà arrivé
d'aller voir une [ __ ] c'est ça apparaît
clairement parce qu'on ne comprend pas
et ça s'est passé comment ça c'est
vachement bien passé mais quand je suis
arrivé à paris le premier truc que j'ai
fait c'est d'aller aux [ __ ] j'étais
fasciné parce qu'en province y en a pas
beaucoup l'annonçaient c'est vraiment un
défi qu'ils peuvent pas faire autre
chose tandis qu'elle paribas il y en a
des belles et toupie j'étais fasciné à
l'idée de donner de l'argent à une fille
pour qu'elle me suce la beach au rsa tu
vois c'est tellement un échange st je
trouve que c'est vachement plus 5 la
secrétaire qui donne son cul par le
d'augmentation je conçois plus plus
propre et est souvent ces défis
formidable ça ma femme elle ne verra pas
sa fille honor tu gagnes convient par
mois s'il ya une pas mal de pognon je
gagne je gagne bien ma vie
combien combien chevalement par contre
j'ai une société moi aussi je gagnais un
petit peu jeu mais grosso modo que tu
joues au théâtre assad
ça fait de vous ça peut friser les cinq
cent mille balles par mois à peu près
bah comme tout le monde un venin
on va juste tout seul alain c'est
pendant tous les jours jeudi en nous un
coup en gagnent 500 1000 et puis un coup
on gagne 300 milles c'est pas on n'est
pas à l'abri
tu vas me rend les galeries qui gagne 6
milles mais c'est tous les mois sa tombe
c'est une sécurité pour avec nous on
n'est jamais à l'abri des trucs moins ça
peut varier de d'un moment à l'autre
tiens toi qu'un comique fait moi rire à
à quelqu'un et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus